I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Hello everybody this is Jenna Fisher. Hi this is Angela Kinsey. And this is our very first Office Ladies podcast. I'm so excited Jenna. I'm so excited I'm a little bit freaking out. I'm freaking out. We hope you guys like it. We have been working really hard. This is a dream
我是詹娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》的终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历其中的两个人才知道的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。大家好，我是詹娜·菲舍尔。大家好，我是安吉拉·金西。这是我们的第一期办公室辣妈播客。我太兴奋了，詹娜。我太兴奋了，我都有点抓狂了。我快抓狂了。希望你们会喜欢。我们一直以来都在努力工作。这是一个梦想
we've had for years of getting to work together again. Yes. Because we became best friends while working on The Office together. We did. We ate lunch together every single day. Every single day. And I think the hardest part for me about the show ending was not getting to see you every day Angela. Me too. It is so special to get to work with your best friend every day. Yes. What a gift. That was the thing you know Steve Carell told us and and I just love this moment so much. He said to Jenna and I no matter what happens with the show this is what you two will take from it. Yeah. And he was so right. It's true. And we've been
我们多年来一直希望能够再次合作。是的。因为我们在共同拍摄《办公室》的过程中成为了最好的朋友。确实如此。我们每天都在一起吃午餐。每天都在一起。我想这部剧结束对我来说最难的部分就是不能每天见到你，安吉拉。我也是。每天能和自己最好的朋友一起工作是多么特别的一件事。是的。真是太棒的礼物了。你知道，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔曾对我们说过这样一番话，我至今依然非常喜欢这个时刻。他对我和詹娜说，无论这部剧发生什么，这是你们两个将从中收获的东西。是的。他说的太对了。确实如此。从那以后我们一直在
trying to figure out some way that we could work together again ever since. So here it is. It's a dream realized. It's a dream realized. We thought what a better time the 15 year anniversary is coming out. And I had like three rubber made bends of photos in my shed and I was going through them and I was getting really nostalgic and I was telling Jenna about it. I was like Jenna we had such an amazing time on that show. I mean it just was one of the joys of my life. And you know I hadn't watched most of the episodes since they aired. So this has been a real treat for me to go back and finally rewatch them. Me too. And it's
寻找再次合作的方法。所以，它来了。梦想成真了。梦想成真了。我们觉得，十五周年纪念日快到了，这是一个绝佳的时机。我在我的棚子里有三大橡胶收纳箱的照片，我翻看它们时感到非常怀旧，并把这事告诉了詹娜。我对她说，詹娜，我们在那部剧里度过了多么美妙的时光啊。我的意思是，那简直是我生命中的快乐源泉之一。你知道，自从剧集播出以来，我几乎就没再看过大部分剧集。所以对我来说，回去最终重新观看它们真是一种享受。我也是。而且
so good. You guys. I mean it really. We've become kind of nerdy fans of our own show. We've become nerdy fans. And here's the thing when we were filming it you're kind of living and breathing the day of it. And I watched them all when they aired. But now I'm watching them just as like an audience. Yes. And it's just so fun. It's been so much fun. And I feel like here it is. It's the office bringing us back together again. Yes. It's so special. It's so special. Okay we're geeking out. We're geeking out. And listen you guys we just want you to know we're so excited that you're gonna like join us in this journey and rewatch every week
太棒了。各位。我是说真的。我们自己都成了这部剧的狂热粉丝了。我们成了狂热粉丝。事情是这样的，当我们在拍摄时，你基本上是在亲历并融入那每一天。剧集播出时我都看了。但现在我只是作为观众在看。是的。真的很有趣。太有趣了。我觉得，看吧，这就是《办公室》把我们重新聚在一起。是的。太特别了。太特别了。好了，我们现在有点疯狂了。我们太激动了。听着，各位，我们只想让你们知道，我们非常高兴你们能加入我们的这段旅程，并且每周都和我们一起
with us. Listen to us chitty chat about being best friends. And there are gonna be times that maybe we forget something right. Or we miss something. Or we miss something. Because we're not experts we just we're on the show. We're on the show and we love the show. You are actually probably the expert. Yes. You guys are the experts. So please watch along with us send in questions. And let's just rewatch it together. And we're gonna start from the beginning. We're gonna start with the pilot and we're gonna watch it in order. Oh my gosh that brings us to the pilot. This is it. This is it. That's what we're gonna talk about today. Okay so just so
重温剧集。听我们唠唠关于成为最好朋友的闲天。有时我们可能会忘掉某些事情，对吧。或者漏掉什么。或者漏掉什么。因为我们不是专家，我们只是参与了这部剧。我们参演了这部剧，而且我们深爱这部剧。你们实际上可能才是专家。是的。你们才是专家。所以请和我们一起看，发来你们的问题。让我们一起重温它吧。我们将从头开始。我们将从试播集开始，并按顺序观看。哦天哪，这就让我们想到了试播集。就是这个。就是这个。这就是我们今天要聊的内容。好吧，为了让你们
you know how Jenna works you guys. She has like her list. She prints out. She has her laptop. She has two notepads. And then I just bring a whole bunch of colored note cards with a Sharpie. If that sort of paints a picture of how we process information. It is. I am a little bit more I don't know. I don't know Jenna. You're more organized. It's okay. You can say it. And you're more colorful. Oh well okay. Well I guess I'm gonna take that as a compliment. All right so let's get started. Let's get started. We're gonna talk about the pilot. This is season one episode one. This episode is written by Ricky Gervais, Steven Merchant and Greg
知道詹娜是如何工作的，各位。她有一份清单。她打印出来了。她带着笔记本电脑。她有两个记事本。而我只是带了一大堆彩色的便签卡和一支马克笔。如果这能说明我们处理信息的方式的话。确实如此。我稍微更……我不知道。我不知道，詹娜。你更有条理。没关系。你可以直说。而且你更多彩。好吧，好吧。那我就把这当作赞美了。好了，那我们开始吧。我们开始吧。我们要聊聊试播集。这是第一季第一集。这一集由里奇·热维斯、斯蒂芬·莫昌特和格雷格
Daniels. And directed by Ken Quapas. Let's start with a synopsis. I think that's a good place to start. Great. All right so in this episode we're gonna meet the employees of Dunder Mifflin Paper Company as introduced by their manager Michael Scott. This is just a normal day at an ordinary like workplace. Just people living their lives. Yes. A pilot episode is usually introducing each of the characters and also the convention of the show. And in this case the convention of the show is that this is a documentary. Right. This is the world you're gonna see every day. Is this paper company? Yes. Now I had an idea. What? I
·丹尼尔斯编剧。由肯·夸帕斯执导。我们从剧情简介开始。我觉得这是个不错的切入点。太好了。那么在这一集中，我们将通过经理迈克尔·斯科特的介绍，结识邓德米夫林纸业公司的员工们。这只是普通工作场所里普通的一天。只是人们在过着各自的生活。是的。试播集通常是用来介绍每个角色的，同时也确立了节目的形式，而在这个案例中，节目的形式是一个纪录片。没错。这就是你每天都能见到的世界。就是这家纸业公司吗？是的。现在我有个想法。什么？我
think for each episode we should have something called fast facts. What are you even talking about? This sounds crazy. A fast fact. What is a fast fact? Okay stay with me here. A fast fact is a fact about that episode. Mm-hmm. And then we talk about it. Not necessarily fast. Wait do I have to talk quickly? No. Here's an example of a fast fact. Okay. The show The Office is actually an adaptation of a British show of the same name. The Office. That's right. It was called The Office. It was written by Ricky Dervais and Steven Merchant. It's fantastic. It is amazing. I was a huge fan of it before I even went to the audition for the
觉得对于每一集，我们都应该设置一个叫做“快速事实”的环节。你在说什么呢？听起来太疯狂了。快速事实。什么是快速事实？好吧，听我说。快速事实就是关于那一集的某个事实。嗯。然后我们来聊聊它。不一定非得很快。等等，我得语速很快吗？不用。这里有一个快速事实的例子。好的。电视剧《办公室》其实是根据同名英国电视剧改编的。名字就叫《办公室》。没错。它就叫《办公室》。由里奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·莫昌特编剧。太棒了。它太神奇了。在我去参加
American version of The Office. Same. I had watched the entire series and then I got a phone call that they were doing an American version and asking me to audition for the receptionist and I about pooped myself. Yeah. Yes. I was excited and nervous because I loved the British version so much and I was like oh I hope they do it justice and I I mean come on. Years later I think I think we did it. Well we got a lot of critical attention when we were making the pilot and not a lot of love because people really thought we were gonna mess it up. People were worried because this the British show was award-winning critically
美版《办公室》试镜之前，我就是它的超级粉丝了。我也是。我看完了整个系列，然后我接到一个电话，说他们正在制作美版，并邀请我去试镜前台接待员的职位，我当时差点吓尿了。是的。是的。我很兴奋也很紧张，因为我太喜欢英版了，心想：哦，我希望他们能拍好，而且我的意思是，拜多年后所赐，我觉得我们做到了。好吧，我们在制作试播集时受到了很多严厉的关注，却没有得到多少喜爱，因为人们真的以为我们会搞砸。人们很担心，因为这部英版电视剧曾获奖项、广受好评
acclaimed. It's considered still to this day one of the greatest television comedies ever made. And it deserves all of that. It is. Because it is amazing. Yes. And so there was a lot of pressure on us when we were going in to make this and something that I think is often said is that we did a shot-by-shot remake of the British pilot which is not true. That is not true. It is not a shot for shot remake but we did use their script as a template and there are some adjustments. There are elements though. There are elements that are the same that if you watch it and watch this one. Yes for example in general each of the characters
并且直到今天，它仍然被认为是史上最伟大的电视喜剧之一。这是它应得的。确实如此。因为它太棒了。是的。所以我们在制作这部剧时承受了很大的压力，而且人们经常说的一件事是，我们对英版试播集进行了逐镜头重拍，其实并不是这样的。那不是真的。它并不是逐镜头重拍，但我们确实以他们的剧本为蓝头，并且做了一些调整。不过其中确实有一些元素。有些元素是相同的，如果你看了英版再看这一版。是的，比如总体上每个角色
and like the fact that there's this buffoonish silly boss in their version named David Brent and ours Michael Scott. But if you look at the talking heads there are some differences. Yes and also like the way the story is told is a little different. I mean some of the points are the same. Yes. That happened but it's told differently. But Greg Daniels was the person who was tasked with Americanizing the British show. Yes. And Ricky Gervais and Steven Merchant kind of oversaw that process but they for example they were not on set when we were shooting the pilot. Nope. No they came and they visited with us. I remember
还有他们的版本中那个名叫大卫·布伦特、愚蠢滑稽的老板，在我们这叫迈克尔·斯科特。但如果你看看“直视镜头访谈”的环节，就会发现一些不同。是的，而且故事的讲述方式也有些许不同。我的意思是，某些情节是一样的。是的。事情发生了，但叙事方式不同。不过格雷格·丹尼尔斯是负责将这部英版剧集美国化的人。是的。里奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·莫昌特在某种程度上监督了这个过程，但例如，当我们拍摄试播集时，他们并不在片场。没有。没有，他们来看望过我们。我记得
sitting and getting to have lunch with Ricky Gervais. Yeah. Oh my gosh because I was so nervous. Oh yes. I was a super fan of the British version. Me too. And I had been cast in the pilot and they came and they listened to us do a table read and afterwards they asked me, John, Rain, Steve and BJ and Greg to join them for lunch to discuss the show. And I remember thinking if I get fired tomorrow at least I got to have lunch with Ricky Gervais and Steven Merchant. At least that happened. That was to me just huge. Was it a fun lunch? I was not at that lunch. I was not invited. It was so much fun Angela. And I remember Ricky saying something in that
我坐下来和里奇·热维斯一起吃午餐。是的。哦天哪，因为我当时太紧张了。哦，是的。我是英版的超级粉丝。我也是。我当时已经被选中参演试播集，他们来听我们进行剧本围读，之后他们邀请我和约翰、雷恩、史蒂夫、BJ以及格雷格一起吃午餐，讨论这部剧。我当时心想，如果我明天被解雇了，至少我和里奇·热维斯还有斯蒂芬·莫昌特一起吃过午餐了。至少这事发生了。对我来说这简直太重要了。那是一顿愉快的午餐吗？我没有去那场午餐。我没有被邀请。午餐非常开心，安吉拉。我记得里奇在
lunch that was really important. He said, you know, in England you can be really, really bad at your job for a long time and you never get fired. He's like, in America that's gonna frustrate people. So my one piece of advice is that Michael can be a buffoon. He can be silly. He can be irritating. But you should, I suggest, he said that you show glimpses of him actually being a good salesperson. And we do that throughout the show. You see in future episodes that he is actually good at sales. And he said that's gonna be an important, I think, piece of the puzzle. And Steven Merchant said, my piece of advice would be to lean a little bit more
那场午餐上说过一件非常重要的话。他说，你知道，在英国，你可以工作很长时间，而且工作表现非常非常糟糕，却永远不会被解雇。他说，在美国，这会让人感到沮丧。所以我的唯一建议是，迈克尔可以是一个小丑。他可以很滑稽。他可以很烦人。但是你应该——我建议，他说——展现出他实际上是一个优秀的销售人员的吉光片羽。我们在整部剧中都做到了这一点。你在之后的剧集中会看到他其实很擅长销售。他说这将是拼图中的一个重要部分。斯蒂芬·莫昌特则说，我的建议是更多地倾向于
into the Jim and Pam relationship. He said, he knew the heart of it. He said, that's really gonna be the heart of your show. Because the British version, they did six episodes for their first season, six episodes for their second season, and one big Christmas special. And they knew that for American television, we were looking to do years and we ended up doing 200. So he said, you need to keep the heart beating on the show. And so that's the heart of the show. That's Jim and Pam. Okay, I have another fast fact. We filmed the pilot six months before the rest of season one. And we shot it on the second floor of a real office building
吉姆和帕姆的关系。他说，他知道核心所在。他说，那将真正成为你们剧集的核心。因为英版的第一季只有六集，第二季六集，还有一个大型圣诞特辑。他们知道，对于美国电视来说，我们希望制作很多年，而我们最终拍了200集。所以他说，你们需要让剧集的核心一直跳动下去。而这正是剧集的核心。也就是吉姆和帕姆。好吧，我还有另一个快速事实。我们在第一季其余部分拍摄前六个月就拍好了试播集。我们在卡尔弗城一栋真正办公楼的二楼进行了拍摄。所以它是一栋真实的办公楼。而且片场通常都会搭建办公室。所以如果要拍摄并获得某种摄像机角度，他们可以移动一面墙。他们可以移动一扇窗户。他们可以移动一门，因为那是搭建出来的。他们甚至会说把墙移开，然后整面墙都被移走了。他们移走了一整面墙。这太疯狂了。在我们的剧中，因为它是一栋真实的办公楼，你只能因地制宜。这也确实契合了纪录片的风格，所有的镜头看起来都不会那么完美。它们无法恰到好处地对齐，因为必须绕过真实的墙壁和
in Culver City. So it was an actual office building. And a lot of times on sets, they build the office. So if they want to film and get a certain camera angle, they can move a wall. They can move a window. They can move a door because they built it. They actually say wall flying out and they move a whole wall. They move a whole wall. It's insane. On our show, because it was in an actual office building, you just had to work with it. And it sort of really lended itself to the documentary style that all the shots weren't gonna look pretty. They weren't gonna be lined up just right because they had to work around actual walls and
窗户。它们不能就这样被拆掉。我记得我和我们的导演肯·夸帕斯谈过，关于为这种纪录片拍摄风格设定某些规则。他说对他来说非常重要的一点是，对于所有的演员和剧组人员来说，片场应该感觉像一个真实运作的办公室，就像正在发生一场真实的纪录片拍摄一样。因此，他想出的规则之一就是，他清空了整个片场的所有剧组人员，只留下一名摄像师、一名录音师和他自己。是的。仅此而已。仅此而已。他还要求所有演员每天早上都来，做完发型和化妆，然后从早上7点30分开始坐在我们的办公桌前
windows. They couldn't just pop them out. I remember speaking to Ken Quapas, our director, about setting certain rules for the documentary style of filming. And he said it was very important to him that for all of the actors and the crew that the set felt like a real working office and a real documentary was happening. And so one of the rules that he came up with was that he cleared the entire set of all crew members except for a camera operator, a boom operator, and himself. Yes. And that was it. That was it. He also made all of the actors come in every morning, go through hair and makeup, and then sit at our desks starting at 7.30
并且我们必须假装在工作。是的。他和纪录片摄制组一起走来走去，拍了我们30分钟。是的，就拍我们安安静静地工作。你所看到的一些小镜头，比如帕姆在使用修正液，就是我们做那些工作早晨之一的B卷素材。我们在试播集的拍摄过程中每天都这么做。关于这一集，我注意到的另一件事是，其中有一个随机的建筑物外景镜头。哦，詹娜，我跟你说。等等，等等，让我拿一张你们所说的彩色便签卡。外景镜头在9分29秒，9分钟29秒处。那不是我们的建筑物。带着一个巨大的感叹
a.m. and we had to pretend to work. Yes. And he walked around with the documentary crew and filmed us for 30 minutes. Yeah, just us quietly working. And little shots that you see, for example, of Pam doing whiteout, that is a piece of B-roll from one of those working mornings that we did. And we did that every day on the pilot. Something else about this episode that I noticed is that there is a random exterior shot of a building. Oh, Jenna, let me tell you. Well, wait, wait, let me grab one of my colorful note cards, as you call them. Exterior shot at 9.29, 9 minutes and 29 seconds. Not our building. With a huge exclamation
号。这是一个重大发现。对我来说这是一个重大发现。不仅不是我们的建筑物，它甚至都不是我们拍摄时所在的建筑物。我不知道他们从哪弄来的那个镜头。那就像是某种资料画面。我觉得那就是资料画面。然后你就再也……我们再也没用过它。就是这样。就这样。他们应该回去把它删掉。再见。然后换上邓德米夫林外景的镜头。詹娜开始对你放肆了。对，我要打电话给某人。找个人把它弄对。好了。这是我的最后一个快速事实。好吧，女士。这一集。好吧，梅雷迪思不是梅雷迪思。她不是。她是亨丽埃特。她是亨丽埃特。是的。梅雷迪思
point. This is a big discovery. This is a big discovery for me. Not only not our building, it wasn't the building we were filming in. I don't know where they got that shot. It's like stock footage from something. I think it was stock footage. And then you never, we never use it again. That was it. That was it. They should go back and take that out. See you later. And put a shot of the reels under Mifflin exterior. Jenna's getting sassy on you. Yeah, I'm gonna call someone. Someone get it right. All right. Here is my last fast fact. Okay, lady. This episode. Okay. Meredith is not Meredith. She is not. She is Henriette. It's Henriette. Yes. Meredith
在试播集中由亨丽埃特·曼特尔饰演，而不是凯特·弗兰纳里。千真万确。亨丽埃特·曼特尔是一位喜剧女演员，她刚刚因为在《布雷迪 Bunch》电影中饰演爱丽丝而崭露头角。她参演了试播集。然后六个月后我们被续订了，接着我们开始拍摄其余的剧集。我猜传闻是她当时没空。她很忙。我们不得不重新选角。于是凯特·弗兰纳里加入了。这是我的快速事实。凯特·弗兰纳里和我早在《办公室》几年前就认识了。我们曾在一个全女性即兴喜剧团里，名叫“贱人星球”。哇呜！星期天晚上大概10点。那就是
is played by Henriette Mantell in the pilot episode, not Kate Flannery. This is true. Henriette Mantell was a comedy actress who had just broken out because she had played Alice in the Brady Bunch films. And she was there for the pilot. And then it was six months later that we got picked up and then we started filming the rest of the episodes. And I guess the rumor was she was not available. She was busy. And we had to recast her. And so Kate Flannery came in. Here is my fast fact. Kate Flannery and I met years before the office. We were in a all-female improv group called Bitch Planet. Wahoo! Sunday nights at like 10 p.m. That's when
你想……那正是你想要喜剧的时候。那正是你想看即兴表演的时候。凯特和我认识很长时间了。而且奥斯卡·努涅斯和我还一起做过一个素描喜剧秀，名叫《热毛巾》。安吉拉，你都是从哪弄来的这些名字？所以对我来说这真的很有趣，因为我当时。就像，我第一天紧张极了。我不知道奥斯卡也被选中了。他也不知道我被选中了。各位，这大约是智能手机出现之前的事。就像，你不会发短信告诉别人你得到了一个角色，也不会把它发到社交媒体上。根本没有这些。所以你走进去，感到完全
you want to... It's exactly when you want your comedy. That's when you want to watch improv. Kate and I had known each other for a really long time. And also Oscar Nunez and I did a sketch comedy show together called Hot Towel. Where do you get these names, Angela? So it was really fun for me because here I am. Like, I was so nervous the first day. I didn't know Oscar had been cast. He didn't know I had been cast. You guys, this was sort of before, this was before smartphones. Like, it's not like you like texted someone you got a role or you put it on your social media. There was none of that. So you walked in and were completely
震惊。当我看到奥斯卡时，我完全震惊了。不仅我看到了奥斯卡，肯·夸帕斯还把我们安排坐在一起。所以我当时想，哦天哪，我会没事的。太棒了。我的好哥们在这。然后布莱恩作为凯文走了进来。我就想，开始了。我们要大干一场了。你们在财务部演得太棒了。谢谢。非常感谢。我在夸你呢。非常感谢。所以，是的，我太高兴了，在我参演《办公室》之前和我一起表演了多年的这些朋友们，正坐在我后边那个小角落里。我记得第一次见到每个人的情景。你还记得你对大家的第一印象吗？我记得我对
surprised. Completely surprised when I saw Oscar. Not only did I see Oscar, but Ken Coapa sat us next to each other. So I was like, oh my god, I'm gonna be okay. That's amazing. My buddy's here. And then Brian walked in as Kevin. I was like, here we go. We're off to the races. You guys were amazing in accounting. Thank you. Thank you so much. I'm giving you a compliment. Thank you so much. So yeah, so I was so excited to have these friends that I had performed with for years before the office sitting in my little corner back there. I remember meeting everyone for the first time. Do you remember your first impressions of people? I remember my
雷恩·威尔逊的第一印象。跟我讲讲。好吧，我是在一次现场试镜中遇到雷恩·威尔逊的。所以对于剧中所有的主角，他们把我们带去进行银幕测试，并把我们混搭在一起。当时有四个帕姆、四个德怀特、四个吉姆和四个迈克尔。是的。我们花了整整一天时间彼此混搭。我记得我遇到了雷恩·威尔逊，他当时正处于角色状态中，但我当时并不知道，因为我还不太认识雷恩。我觉得他是我这辈子见过的最怪异的人。等等，他全程都处在角色状态中吗？是的。他就是德怀特。哦，所以是方法派雷恩。他的发型就是那样的。
first impression of Rainn Wilson. Tell me. Well, I met Rainn Wilson at a live test audition. So for all the leads of the show, they brought us into screen test and they mixed and matched us. There were four Pam's and four Dwight's and four Jim's and four Michaels. Yeah. And we spent an entire day being mixed and matched with each other. And I remember I met Rainn Wilson and he was in character, but I couldn't really know that because I didn't know Rainn yet. And I thought he was the weirdest person I'd ever met in my life. Wait, he was in character the whole time? Yeah. He just was Dwight. Oh, so method Rainn. He had his hair like that.
哦，太方法派了。但你知道吗？我其实也做了类似的事。我做了我的帕姆发型。我在剧中梳的发型，是我在试镜过程中琢磨出来的，那种半扎半放、用发圈绑的、自然风干的卷发。所以我当时很安静。我在候诊室里不和别人说话，因为我觉得帕姆不是那种爱聊天的人，我不想跳出角色。我记得最早的事情之一。这听起来很随机，但千真万确。拍摄第一周时，雷恩的妻子来吃午餐，这是我记忆中试播集期间雷恩的主要互动。雷恩把
Oh, so method. But you know what? I kind of did the same thing. I did my Pam hairstyle. The hairstyle that I wore on the show, I sort of invented through the audition process that sort of half up, half down, scrunchy, air-dried curl. And so I was very quiet. I didn't talk to people in the waiting room because I just thought Pam was sort of not a chatter and I didn't want to get out of character. I remember one of the first things. This is so random, but it's true. That first week of filming Rainn's wife came to have lunch and this is the the main interaction I remember from Rainn during the pilot episode. Rainn introduced
他妻子介绍给我。她当时怀着他们的儿子。是的。他说，这是我的妻子霍莉，我骨肉的承载者。当时我就想，什么？然后她笑了起来。但那只是雷恩在做雷恩会做的事。那是雷恩。那就是雷恩，但德怀特不就会这么说吗？他确实也会这么说。这是安吉拉，我骨肉的承载者。是的。她怀着我的骨肉。我心想：哦天哪。我觉得我们每个人身上都有自己角色的影子。但我不知道这是否适用于你，因为你和安吉拉·马丁完全相反。我是。我刚刚在想你说的，你在试镜大厅等待时一直保持着角色状态，雷恩也是。换作我可不会。我会一直聊天聊天聊天。然后当我走进房间时，我就会立刻变成一个碧池。好吧，你知道的，我在试播集中和雷恩没有什么实质性的对手戏。我没有什么一对一的场景。所以对我来说，当我们拍摄试播集时，我真正建立深厚感情的人是史蒂夫、约翰和你，因为你就在隔壁那一小块。你是我在办公室里靠得最近的邻居。所以你和我建立了感情。我记得在我们拍完试播集后，大家都离开了，我们不知道自己是否会被续订或者还会不会继续拍。在那之后不久，我迎来了30
me to his wife. She was pregnant at the time with their son. Yes. And he said, this is my wife Holly, bearer of my seed. And I was like, what? And she started laughing. But that was just Rainn being Rainn. That's Rainn. That is Rainn, but wouldn't Dwight say that? He would also say that. This is Angela, bearer of my seed. Yes. She's carrying my seed. I'm like, oh my god. I feel like we all had little parts of our characters in us. But I don't know if that's true of you because you are so opposite from Angela Martin. I am. I was thinking about how you were saying, like, you stayed in character and so did Rainn in between your auditions in the
岁生日。对我的一个重大里程碑生日。我真的很纠结是否应该邀请你们任何人。结果我没有。我没有邀请你们，因为我想，好吧，我可能再也见不到他们了。我要不要再给你办个30岁生日派对然后邀请所有人？你会吗？然后我们就可以说生日快乐了。你会吗？好吧。因为现在你们成了我最要好的朋友，而你们当时却没有出席我的里程碑生日。好吧，我们必须给你办个30岁生日派对。一点也不会尴尬。好了，各位。接下来，我们要剖析这一集。我们要深入了解其中的细节。我们将谈论场景、回忆和故事。所以请继续收听。好的，我们回来了。我们在讨论《办公室》的试播集，我觉得我们应该聊聊一些我们最喜欢的时刻，詹娜。是的。嗯，我最喜欢的时刻之一就是帕姆和迈克尔之间的化学反应。我的意思是，自私地说，我大概也参与了那个时刻。但我真的很喜欢和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔合作。我真的很喜欢他允许我保持沉默、只是看着他并作出反应。是的，我很喜欢那样。但我尤其喜欢莫洛拉·哈丁（饰演简·莱文森·古尔德）加入其中的时候。她太有威严了。仅仅是莫洛拉的存在感就让我……我很怕她。是的。我懂。我明白为什么他有点怕她了。我喜欢迈克尔试图让帕姆背锅的那场戏，解释他为什么没有本该准备好的议程。因为他告诉帕姆把它扔进容器里，也就是那个作为公司备忘录专用文件柜的垃圾桶里。我还记得拍摄那场戏的情景。我只记得每次帕姆说“你让我把它放进一个当作垃圾桶的专用文件柜里”时，我们都会咯咯笑。所以我只记得那一刻的绝对自然，以及那有多么有趣。帕姆在那个时刻完全以她自己的小方式
lobby. I would not have. I would have been like, chitty chat chat. And then I would have just turned into a bitch when I entered the room. Well, you know, I didn't have any scenes with Rainn in the pilot of substance. I didn't have any one-on-one scenes. So for me, when we were shooting the pilot, the people that I really bonded with were Steve, John, and you because you were over the little part. You were my closest seatmate in the office. So you and I bonded. And I remember after we finished the pilot and we all left and we didn't know if we were going to be picked up or make any more. Shortly after that, I turned 30
为自己挺身而出。关于史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，事情是这样的。他是我见过最好的人之一。他真的太好了。我知道这甚至有点像个笑话，比如史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是史上最好的人，但他真的是。我知道。人们经常问我，和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔合作是什么感觉？你们是不是一直在笑？其实并没有，你不会一直在笑，因为史蒂夫并不是无时无刻都在搞笑。他不是那种人。他是一个真实的人。他是一个真实的人。而且，我合作过一些无时无刻不在搞笑的喜剧演员。你走在他们旁边，你就能感觉到，他们的大脑无法关掉制造笑话的开关。
years old. It was a big milestone birthday for me. And I really wondered if I should invite any of you guys. And I didn't. I didn't invite you guys because I thought, well, I'm probably never going to see them again. Should I throw you another 30th birthday party and invite everyone? Would you? And then we could just say happy 30th. Will you? Okay. Because now you guys are some of my closest friends and you aren't at my milestone birthday. Okay, we have to throw you a 30th birthday party. It won't be weird. All right, guys. So next up, we are going to break down this episode. We're going to really get into the nitty
我开着车，抱歉。这有点疯狂。史蒂夫不是那样的人。你、史蒂夫和我经常坐在一起，长时间地聊圣费尔南多谷最好吃的冷冻酸奶。哦，我永远不会忘记那个早晨。在周一早晨，史蒂夫会走出他的办公室，也就是迈克尔·斯科特的办公室，在两场戏的间隙。他会走到詹娜和我身边，我们一起聊我们的周末。某个周一早上，他走过来对我们说：“女士们，猜猜我这个周末干了什么？”我们说：“干了什么？”他说：“我去塔吉特了。”他会跟我们聊塔吉特。他跟我们讲了他去塔吉特的经历。真的，
gritty. We're going to talk about scenes and memories and stories. So stick with us. All right, and we're back. We're talking about the pilot episode of the office. And I think we should talk about some of our favorite moments, Jenna. Yes. Well, one of my favorite moments is the dynamic between Pam and Michael. I mean, selfishly, I guess I'm in that moment. But I really loved working with Steve Carell. I really loved how much he let me be silent and just look at him and just react. Yes, I loved that. But I especially love whenever Malora Hardin, who plays Jan Levinson Gould, got in the mix. She's so commanding. Just like Malora's
真的非常贴心。你知道，最近我在一家迈克尔斯手工艺品店为手工活采购一些用品。收银员说：“哦天哪，这太疯狂了。今天早上奥斯卡·努涅斯来过这儿。然后是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，现在是你，你们俩是都住在这里吗？”我们太喜欢做手工了。我们太喜欢做手工了。我们都在这儿。我们所有人都，我想我们大概都住在离这家迈克尔斯手工艺品店不远的地方。是的。我给史蒂夫发短信说：“史蒂夫，迈克尔斯的收银员告诉我你今天买了一些手工艺品。”他说：“哦，是的，我需要一些胶棒。”他告诉我他需要什么。他说：“你那天去那儿干什么？”但这就是史蒂夫。这就是史蒂夫。这就是我们会和他聊的那类话题。所以后来，当这个男人转换到这样一个场景中，他对我的角色态度恶劣，比如在大老板女士面前让你背锅。是的。而我们现实中的化学反应明明是如此充满爱。所以在那个场景中，简告诉迈克尔，公司要进行裁员了。是的。这是个大新闻。这很重要。迈克尔应该给予关注。我们已经确定他把会议的议程给扔了。是的，他应该严肃对待这件事。但相反，他接到了
presence is like, I'm scared of her. Yes. I get it. I get why he was a little scared of her. And I love the scene where Michael tries to throw Pam under the bus about why he doesn't have the agenda that he's supposed to have. And it's because he told her to throw it in the receptacle, the trash can that is a special filing cabinet for corporate memos. And I remember shooting that scene. And I just remember every time that Pam said, you told me to put it in a special filing cabinet that is a trash can that we would giggle. And so I just remember the matter of factness of that moment and how fun that was. Pam totally stood up
他的朋友托德·帕克的电话。托德·帕克，他的派对搭子。他显然很羡慕这个人。他觉得这家伙棒极了。关于这个场景的另一个有趣事实是，电话里传出的托德·帕克的配音并不是真正的托德·帕克的配音。你在说什么呢？戴夫·科克纳最后饰演了托德·帕克。当我们在第二季中见到他时，这个角色是由戴夫·科克纳饰演的。但当我们拍摄试播集时，戴夫并没有被雇佣。什么？他没有。等等，所以我一直觉得那听起来像戴夫·科克纳。那是谁？但我心想那不可能是戴夫·科克纳，对吧？这么久以来。我一直以为是戴夫·科克纳。
for herself in her own little way in that moment. Here's the thing about Steve Krell. He is one of the nicest people you will ever meet. He is so nice. I know it's almost even become like a joke, like Steve Krell's the nicest person ever, but he is. I know. And people ask me a lot, what's it like to work with Steve Krell? Are you just laughing all the time? And no, you're not laughing all the time because Steve isn't on all the time. He's not one of those. He's a real person. He's a real person. And he's, I've worked with comedians who are on all the time. You walk around and you can just, they can't turn off their joke making brain.
那不是戴夫。那是谁？我给我们的剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯发了短信。戴夫·罗杰斯。无所不知的人。我的意思是，他了解《办公室》的所有事实。他确实是。好吧。戴夫说什么了？戴夫说那个声音是由托比·胡斯配的。托比·胡斯。是的。非常著名的配音演员。他多年来一直是《山丘之王》的主演。而且他是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的朋友。是的。托比·胡斯太有才华了。我知道。怎么样？那是试播集中托德·帕克的配音。是的。好吧，我很喜欢。这是我喜欢试播集的原因之一，还有里奇·热维斯、斯蒂芬·莫昌特和格雷格·丹尼尔斯及其团队合作构建这个世界的才华在于，
I drive my car, sorry. It's a little insane. Steve is not like that. You and Steve and I would sit and have long conversations about the best frozen yogurt in the San Fernando Valley. Oh, I will never forget the morning. On Monday mornings, Steve would come out of his office, out of Michael Scott's office between scenes. He would walk over to Jenna and I and we would talk about our weekends. And one Monday morning he walked over and he was like, ladies, guess what I did this weekend? We're like, what? And he goes, I went to Target. He would talk to us about Target. And he told us about his Target run. It was really,
许多关于角色的真实特质都是通过这些微妙的方式确立的。我最喜欢的一点是，迈克尔显然对摄像人员的到来感到欣喜若狂。哦，他太兴奋了。他恨不得立刻就答应下来。我的意思是，他抓住这个机会不放。而且他认为自己是世界上最好的喜剧演员之一。哦，是的。世界上最搞笑的人之一。他有一段精彩的直视镜头访谈，谈到了谁是他的英雄。是的。他们是鲍勃·霍普、亚伯拉罕·林肯、博诺，大概还有上帝。他说大概是上帝。这里有个小花絮。史蒂夫
really sweet. You know, recently I was in a Michaels purchasing some supplies for a crafting job. And the checkout guy said, Oh my gosh, now this is getting crazy. This morning, Oscar Nunez came in here. Then Steve Carell and now you, what do you guys all live here? We love crafting. We love crafting. We're all here. We're all sort of, I guess we all live around this one Michaels crafting store. Yeah. I texted Steve and I said, Steve, the checkout guy at Michaels told me you were buying some crafting supplies today. And he said, Oh, yes, I needed some glue sticks. He told me what he needed. He's like, what were you
写了那段台词。真的吗？是的。哦天哪。我太喜欢了。我不知道。是的。格雷格问他：“你介意写一份你认为的迈克尔·斯科特的英雄名单吗？”哦，太精彩了。鲍勃·霍普。然后它被收录进去了。是的。而且他只要有机会，就会看着镜头并表演他的喜剧桥段。这确立了迈克尔对被喜欢和被欣赏的渴望。他想让每个人都觉得他是那个有趣的Boss。而且他认为自己确实很有才华。哦，还有那个他模仿《无敌金刚》的场景，他从帕姆的桌子旁走开。是的。我根本没办法顺利拍完那场戏。
there for? But that is Steve. That is Steve. That's the kind of stuff we would talk to him about. And so to then, to have that man then shift into this scene where he's just being awful to my character, like throwing you under the bus in front of the big boss lady. Yes. When our real dynamic was just like so much, so much love. So in the scene, Jan tells Michael, there's going to be downsizing. Yeah. This is big news. This is important. Michael should be paying attention. We've already established that he's thrown away the agenda for the meeting. Yeah, he should take this seriously. But instead, he takes a phone
事实上，为了拍出我的反应镜头，他们不得不让史蒂夫离开片场，因为我根本笑得停不下来。所以那个反应。是的。我的那个反应并不是在史蒂夫实际做那个动作时拍的，因为他每次做那个动作，我都笑场了。是的。好吧，他太兴奋于表演他的《无敌金刚》了。我计算过时间，因为我在看的时候心想：“哇，维持这个梗这么长时间真是不容易”，因为他一直在做。它从9分40秒开始，一直持续到10分02秒才结束。哦天哪。那是整整22秒的慢动作桥段。我想这就是为什么，那太漫长了。当你考虑到一整集的篇幅时，为了这22秒，你去了，我的意思是，这可能就是为什么我无法拍完的原因。这就是为什么他们拍不到我的反应，因为我没法保持22秒。我没办法保持严肃那么久。而且他非常渴望你看他一眼并做出某种反应。天哪。好吧。还有什么？还有什么？还有会议室的场景。哦，是的。迈克尔正式宣布邓德米夫林将要裁员。这是试播集的一个大主题。这是简来到办公室时告诉他的新闻，邓德米夫林
call from his friend, Todd Packer. Todd Packer, his party buddy. He clearly covets. He thinks this guy's amazing. Another interesting fact about this scene is that the voice of Todd Packer that comes on the phone is not the voice of the real Todd Packer. What are you talking about? Dave Kekner ends up playing Todd Packer. When we meet him in season two, this role is played by Dave Kekner. But Dave was not hired when we shot the pilot. What? He's not. Wait, so I was think it sounds like Dave Kekner. Who is it? But I'm thinking it can't be Dave Kekner, right? It's all this time. I thought it was Dave Kekner.
无法同时支撑斯克兰顿分公司和斯坦福分公司，他们必须证明哪个分公司应该留下来。但即使斯克兰顿留下来，也可能会有员工裁员。是的。公司正在遭受损失，他们必须削减开支，必须解雇一些人。是的。于是迈克尔走进会议室，这是我们第一次在会议室里看到迈克尔。当然，德怀特不会给他空间来做这件事。这是他们的第一次权力争斗，你将在未来几年里一直看到。这是他第一次自称助理
It's not Dave. Who is it? I texted Dave Rogers, our editor. Dave Rogers. Knower of all things. I mean, he is knower of all office facts. He is. Okay. What did Dave say? Dave said that the voice is played by Toby Huss. Toby Huss. Yes. Very famous voice actor. He was king of the hill for years. And friends of Greg Daniels. Yes. Toby Huss is so talented. I know. How about that? That is Todd Packer's voice in the pilot episode. Yes. Well, I loved. Here's one of the things I loved about the pilot and just sort of the brilliance that was Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant and Greg Daniels and their collaboration building this world
区域经理。是的。这太棒了。我注意到了会议室场景的一个细节。什么？我敢说我的便签卡上有记。我敢说你记下了这个场景中有一些以后再也见不到的临时演员。有两个女人。你想让我查一下吗？让我直接告诉你我在便签卡上写了什么。好的。会议室面孔。分号。所以在背景中，有两个女人，她们是我们剧组真正的制片公司会计。是的。我们需要更多人来填满空间，于是他们把制片办公室的真实会计拉了过来。是的。肯·夸帕斯，导演，走进制片办公室，问有没有人愿意在场景的背景中露面。那两个女人就走过来，在那里坐了几个小时。她们太兴奋了。她们太喜欢了。太喜欢了。然后，在会议室里，你会看到一些面孔在第一季中零星出现，但没有延续到之后的季节，那就是露安·凯利，她在附楼工作。是的。她是你在剧中经常看到的人。我经常被问到：附楼里的那个女人是谁？是的。她坐在差不多米迪最终坐的那个位置。是的。在凯利的桌子旁边。当然还有
out is that so many like truths about the characters were established in all these subtle ways. And one of the things I loved is that Michael is clearly thrilled that the camera people are there. Oh, he is so excited. He could not have signed up for this faster. I mean, he jumped at the chance at this. And he thinks he is one of the world's best comedians. Oh, yeah. In the world. He is one of the funniest people in the world. He has that amazing talking head where he talks about who his heroes are. Yes. And they are Bob Hope, Abraham Lincoln, Bono, and God probably. He said probably God. And here's a little tidbit. Steve
德文和克里德，他们最终在后面确实有自己的故事线。直到第二季才有。没错。所以整整一季，你只能在场景的背景中看到德文和克里德。直到第二季他们才有台词。但那是我们真正的会计参演的唯一一场戏，因为他们随后必须回去工作。是的。他们必须回去继续当剧组的会计。我觉得这是一个有趣的八卦。在剧中饰演菲利斯的菲利斯·史密斯，她曾是《办公室》的选角助理。所以当我为《办公室》试镜时，她和我一起对台词。
wrote that. He did. Yes. Oh my God. I love that. I didn't know that. Yeah. Greg asked him, would you mind writing a list of who you believe are Michael Scott's heroes? Oh, so brilliant. Bob Hope. And it made it in. Yes. Well, and he just every chance he gets, he's like looking to the camera and doing his comedy bits. And this sort of sets up just Michael's love of being liked and being appreciated. And he wants everyone to think he's like the fun boss. And he, he thinks he's legitimately talented. Well, there's that scene where he does the $6 million man where he's walking away from Pam's desk. Yes. I could not get through that scene. And in
每个人。我和菲利斯对我的戏份。那就是和我对台词的人。是的。导演肯·夸帕斯对她与演员对台词的表现印象深刻。各位，她太真诚了。她真的是太真诚了。而且那么真实，以至于他对格雷格·丹尼尔斯说：“我想让她参演这部剧。我能给她安排一个剧中的角色吗？”于是菲利斯从一个选角助理——她和选角导演艾莉森·琼斯一起做了多年的工作——变成了在这部试播集中拥有一个角色。我想因为我们当时都觉得这部剧没前途，所以也无所谓。试播集结束后，她又回去做
fact, in order to get my reaction shot, they had to make Steve leave the set because I couldn't get through it. So that react. Yes. That reaction of me was not while Steve was actually doing anything because every time he did it, I started laughing. Yeah. Well, he's so giddy to do his $6 million man. I timed it because as I watched it, I was like, wow, this is a long time to commit to this bit because he's like, he did it. It started at nine minutes, 40 seconds. And he, it doesn't end until 10 minutes, two seconds. Oh my gosh. That is 22 seconds of the slow mo bit. I think that's why that's a ton. When you think
选角助理了。她直接回去工作了。菲利斯有一个很棒的故事，她是这样讲述的。她发现自己得到了菲利斯这个角色的方式是，她拿到了剧本，上面写着“菲利斯”。所以剧里有一个角色，名字叫菲利斯。肯对她说：“那就是你。你就是菲利斯。”她当时想：什么？我们根据你和演员们无数次的对台词经历为你写了一个角色。你现在是剧中的菲利斯了。这真的很酷，因为菲利斯一直想当演员。她当过演员。她曾是一名滑稽歌舞杂耍舞蹈演员。没有人能像菲利斯那样扭动。她的扭动太棒了。她的桌子上有一张很棒的照片，因为肯·夸帕斯
of like the whole scope of an episode for 22 seconds, you went, I mean, that's probably why I couldn't get through it. That's why they couldn't get a reaction of me because I couldn't hold it for 20 seconds. I couldn't hold a straight face that long. And he was so desperate for you to look at him and have some kind of reaction. Oh man. Okay. What else? What else? There's the conference room scene. Oh, yes. Where Michael officially announces that there is going to be downsizing at Dunder Mifflin. This is a big theme of the pilot. This is the news that Jan gives him when she comes into the office that Dunder Mifflin can no
希望我们在试播集及以后个性化我们的办公桌。所以我们都从家里带了一些东西。我带了一张我和祖母的照片，在一个写着“我爱奶奶”的相框里。照片里我的眼睛是闭着的，但我的祖母还是把它装裱了起来。所以我把它放在我的桌子上，这让我觉得很好笑，也让我想起了我的祖母。我带了一张我和妹妹在奥沙克湖游泳的照片。是的。而菲利斯带了一张她穿着全套滑稽歌舞服装的照片，肩上披着一条红色的羽毛波阿围巾。安吉拉，我们休息一下吧。好的，詹娜。你要去
longer support both a Scranton branch and a Stanford branch and that they're going to have to prove who is the branch that should stay. But even if Scranton gets to stay, there might be downsizing of employees. Yeah. The company's hurting and they have to make some cutbacks and they have to fire some people. Yes. And so Michael goes into the conference room and this is the first time we see Michael in the conference room. And of course Dwight won't give him the space to do that. It's their first power struggle, which you'll see for years to come. It's the first time he refers to himself as the assistant
不再同时支持斯克兰顿分公司和斯坦福分公司，他们必须证明哪个分公司应该留下来。但即使斯克兰顿得以保留，也可能会裁减员工。是的。公司遇到了困难，必须削减开支，还不得不解雇一些人。是的。于是迈克尔走进会议室，这是我们第一次看到迈克尔在会议室里。当然，德怀特不会给他这个空间。这是他们的第一次权力斗争，你将在未来几年里看到这一点。这是他第一次把自己称为助理
regional manager. Yeah. Which is great. And I noticed something about this conference room scene. What? I bet I have it on my note card. I bet you have it that there are some extras in this scene that are never to be seen again. There are two women. Do you want me to refer to it? Let me just tell you what I wrote on my note card. Okay. Conference room faces. Simicolon. So in the background, there are two women and they are the real production company accountants for our show. Yes. We needed more people to fill out the space and they pulled in our actual accountants from our production office. Yes. Ken Guapas, the
地区经理。是的。这太棒了。我注意到这个会议室场景的一个细节。什么？我打赌我的便签上有。我打赌你写的是这个场景里有些龙套演员以后再也不会出现了。有两个女人。你想让我提一下吗？我来告诉你我在便签上写了什么。好的。会议室面孔。分号。所以在背景里，有两个女人，她们是我们节目的真实制作公司会计。是的。我们需要更多的人来填满空间，于是他们把我们制作办公室的真实会计拉了过来。是的。肯·夸帕斯，这位
director, walked into the production office and asked if anyone would like to be in the background of a scene. And those two women came and sat there for that couple of hours. They were so giddy. They loved it. They loved it. They loved it. And then also in the conference room, some faces you might see sprinkled through the first season, but then they don't go past that season are Luanne Kelly, who worked in the Annex. Yes. She is someone that you see a lot. I get asked a lot. Who is the lady in the Annex? Yes. She was sort of over where Mindy ends up sitting. Yes. By Kelly's desk. And then also, of course, Devon
导演走进制作办公室，问有没有人想在场景背景里露面。那两个女人就来了，在那里坐了那几个小时。她们太兴奋了。她们太喜欢了。她们太喜欢了。然后，在会议室里，你可能会在第一季中零星看到一些面孔，但之后就没有再出现过，那就是在附楼工作的露安·凯利。是的。她是一个你经常看到的人。我经常被问到。附楼里的那个女士是谁？是的。她的位置有点像明迪最后坐的地方。是的。在凯利的桌子旁边。然后当然还有德文
and Creed, who ultimately do have a storyline that will come later. Not until season two. That's right. So for an entire season, you just see Devon and Creed in the background of scenes. They don't get any lines until the second season. But that is the only scene our actual accountants are in because then they had to go back to work. They did. They had to actually go back to being accountants for the show. I think this is an interesting tidbit. Phyllis Smith, who plays Phyllis on the show, she was the casting associate for the office. So when I auditioned for the office, she read my audition scenes with me.
和克里德，他们最终确实有一个稍后才会展开的剧情线。直到第二季才出现。没错。所以整整一季，你只能在场景背景中看到德文和克里德。直到第二季他们才拿到任何台词。但那是我们真正的会计出演的唯一一场戏，因为之后他们必须回去工作。是的。他们实际上不得不回去当节目的会计。我认为这是一个有趣的内幕消息。菲利斯·史密斯，她在剧中饰演菲利斯，她曾是《办公室》的选角助理。所以当我为《办公室》试镜时，她和我一起读了我的试镜剧本。
Everyone. I read my scene with Phyllis. That's who I read my scene with. Yes. And Ken Quapas, the director, was so taken with how she did her readings with the actors. She's so earnest, you guys. She is so earnest. And so real that he said to Greg Daniels, I want her on the show. Can I give her a part on the show? And so Phyllis went from being a casting associate, which she had done for years with Alison Jones, the casting director, worked with Phyllis to having a part on this pilot. And I think because we all thought the show was going nowhere, it was fine. And after the pilot was over, she went back to being a casting
每个人。我和菲利斯一起读了我的剧本。这就是和我一起读剧本的人。是的。导演肯·夸帕斯对她与演员对词的表现印象深刻。她太真诚了，伙计们。她太真诚了。而且如此真实，以至于他对格雷格·丹尼尔斯说，我想让她上节目。我能在节目里给她一个角色吗？于是菲利斯从一个选角助理——她和选角导演艾莉森·琼斯一起做了多年的工作——变成了在这个试播集中拥有一个角色。我想因为我们都以为这节目没前途，所以也无所谓。试播集结束后，她又回去做选角
associate. She went right back to work. Phyllis has a great story that she tells it. The way she found out that she got Phyllis is that she got sides and they said Phyllis. So there was a character and they named it Phyllis. And Ken was like, that's you. You're Phyllis. And she was like, what? We wrote a part for you based on the numerous readings with actors. You're now in the show Phyllis. Which is just so cool because Phyllis had wanted to be an actress. She had been an actress. She had been a burlesque dancer. No one can shimmy. No one can shimmy like Phyllis. Like she has a great shimmy. She had an amazing photo on her desk because Ken
助理了。她直接回去工作了。菲利斯有一个很棒的故事。她发现自己得到了菲利斯这个角色的过程是，她收到了剧本页，上面写着菲利斯。所以有一个角色，他们给它命名为菲利斯。肯当时说，那就是你。你就是菲利斯。她当时想，什么？我们根据与演员的无数次对词为你写了一个角色。你现在加入节目了，菲利斯。这真是太酷了，因为菲利斯一直想成为一名演员。她曾是一名演员。她曾是一名滑稽舞演员。没有人能扭动。没有人能像菲利斯那样扭动。她跳舞太棒了。她的桌子上有一张惊艳的照片，因为肯
Quapas wanted us to personalize our desk for the pilot episode and moving forward. So we all brought in something from home. I have a photo of myself and my grandmother in a frame that says, I heart grandma. And my eyes are closed in the photo, but my grandmother framed it anyway. And so I have that on my desk and it just kind of like tickled me and made me think of my grandmother. I had a picture of me and my sister swimming in Lake of the Ozarks. Yes. And Phyllis had a picture of herself in her full burlesque outfit with a red feather boa draped over her shoulders. Angela, let's take a quick break. Okay, Jenna. You gonna get a
夸帕斯希望我们在试播集及以后个性化我们的办公桌。所以我们都从家里带了一些东西。我有一张我和祖母的照片，在一个写着“我爱奶奶”的相框里。照片里我的眼睛是闭着的，但我的祖母还是把它装裱了起来。所以我把它放在桌上，这让我觉得很有趣，也让我想起了我的祖母。我有一张我和姐姐在奥扎克斯湖游泳的照片。是的。而菲利斯有一张她穿着完整的滑稽舞服装、肩膀上披着红色羽毛围巾的照片。安吉拉，我们休息一下吧。好的，珍娜。你要去
snack? Why? Because you always get a snack during the breaks. I do. So then we get to that crazy scene where Michael is walking Ryan the temp around. So he's just been told that we need downsizing. And then he hires a temp. He hires some. The opposite of downsizing. Can I just say one thing I love too is when Dwight has his talking head and he said, I've been talking about downsizing for years. I brought it up in my interview. Like who does that? Who's like interviewing for a job and is like, you should downsize. I would like this job. I suggest you get rid of three other people. So here's a little fun fact. It's not a fast fact, but
零食？为什么？因为你在休息时间总能吃到零食。我确实会。然后我们就演到了那个疯狂的场景：迈克尔带着新来的实习生瑞恩四处参观。他刚刚得知公司需要精简人员。然后他雇了一个实习生。他雇了一些人。这完全跟精简人员背道而驰。我能说一说我特别喜欢的一个地方吗？就是德怀特在面对镜头独白时说，我好几年都在谈论精简人员了。我在面试时就提出来了。谁会干这种事啊？谁去面试工作时会说，你们应该精简人员。我想要这份工作。我建议你们裁掉其他三个人。所以这里有个有趣的冷知识。这不是一个快节奏的知识，但是
a fun fact is that BJ Novak was the first person cast on the show. He was? He was. Greg Daniel saw him doing stand up comedy and he thought he was like this guy. I want this guy. And so he offered BJ a role as both a writer and the role of Ryan the temp on the show. So when I came in for my audition, BJ was already cast. He was the very first person. And he was also the first example of that synergy of having people who were both performers and writers for the show, which was so great. Something that we haven't talked about, but we will talk about it many times as the show goes, is that what a wonderful creative
一个有趣的冷知识是，BJ·诺瓦克是剧组第一个确定出演的人。是吗？是的。格雷格·丹尼尔斯看到他在做单口喜剧，他觉得这人太棒了。我就要这个人。于是他向BJ提供了一个双重角色，既是编剧，又饰演剧中的实习生瑞恩。所以当我来试镜的时候，BJ已经定下来了。他是第一个被选上的人。他也是剧组演员兼编剧这种黄金组合的第一个范例，这真的很棒。我们之前没怎么聊过，但随着节目的推进，我们以后会经常聊到这一点，那就是编剧和演员之间
collaboration we had between the writers and the actors. And that was because of Greg Daniels. He sort of set the tone that he wanted this creative collaboration. He wanted to hear our ideas and he wanted writers on the set. And I think we were just so much the better for it. I've been on other shows now that where the writers and the actors are separate and there's not a lot of collaboration. And it feels weird after having experienced something else. No, Greg really trusted us to be the experts of our characters. So whenever he was trying to mull something over or justify something, he would come to us
有着多么美妙的创意合作。这全都要归功于格雷格·丹尼尔斯。他定下了基调，他希望有这种创意合作。他想听听我们的想法，他希望编剧们也留在片场。我想我们真的因此受益匪浅。我现在参与过其他一些剧集，那里的编剧和演员是分开的，没有什么合作。在经历过这种（《办公室》的）模式之后，会觉得那种感觉怪怪的。不，格雷格真的很信任我们，让我们成为各自角色的专家。所以每当他试图斟酌某件事或给某事寻找合理性时，他都会来找我们
and ask us just in the way that he went to Steve and said, Hey, do you have any thoughts on who Michael Scott's heroes would be? Yeah. He trusted us to have done our homework and know our character so well that we could contribute. Yeah, it was great. It was really special. So also in that scene, that is the famous stapler in Jell-O. Yaw. The stapler goes in Jell-O. Yaw. I have seen so many people recreate this. How? How? I am blown away. Every time I see a fan tag me in a photo where they put something in Jell-O, I'm like, I'm very impressed. Where to go? I know. Something we haven't mentioned is the flirtation between Jim and Pam in this
向我们请教，就像他去找史蒂夫说：“嘿，你对迈克尔·史密斯的偶像是谁有什么想法吗？”是的。他信任我们做过功课，对自己的角色了如指掌，所以我们能够贡献出自己的想法。是的，这太棒了。真的很特别。所以也是在这个场景中，出现了那个著名的果冻订书机。哦。订书机被放进了果冻里。哦。我看到过好多人重现这个场景。怎么做到的？怎么做到的？我太震撼了。每当看到有粉丝发照片圈我，里面放着果冻制品时，我都觉得，太佩服了。真有一套。没错。我们还没提到的一点是，吉姆和帕姆在这集里的
episode. And it goes on through the whole first two-thirds of this episode or three-quarters of this episode. Little, little things. What did I write on my pink note card, Jenna? Mixed berries. And quotes. He's on to me. Yeah. That is one of the cutest things. It is so pure. It is. Like that's, that's flirting for them. That he knows your favorite yogurt. But up until the end, you are just sort of following this flirtation between the two characters and then all of a sudden Roy walks in the door. David Dinman. Carrying that weird trash bag. We never know what's in that trash bag. What is he carrying? I loved it so much when, when
调情。这种调情贯穿了这集的前三分之二或四分之三。一点点小动作。我在粉色便签上写了什么，珍娜？混合浆果。还有引号。他发现我了。是的。这是最可爱的事情之一。太纯真了。确实。对他们来说，这就算调情了。他竟然知道你最喜欢的酸yogurt。但在最后关头，你还只是顺着看这两个角色的调情，结果罗伊突然走进了门。大卫·丹曼。提着那个奇怪的垃圾袋。我们永远不知道那个垃圾袋里装着什么。他提着的是什么？我太喜欢了，当
John is Jim is like, what's in the bag? And Roy's like, yeah, just tell her. Yeah, tell her I'll meet her in the car. Yeah. But I think it is such a, I remember watching the pilot with people and having them be shocked. Yeah. Like, oh wait. Oh crap. She's been engaged three years. Three years to this guy. Holy moly. Yeah. And then Jim has that heartbreaking talking head. Do I think I'll be invited to the wedding? Oh, Jim. Breaking hearts. He's breaking hearts. Right out of the gate. He's breaking hearts. He really is. So another really cute, flirty moment between Jim and Pam. After the conference room scene where we all find out there's
约翰饰演的吉姆问：“袋子里是什么？”然后罗伊说：“行了，告诉她吧。告诉她我在车里等她。”是的。但我认为这真的是，我记得和大家一起看试播集时，大家都惊呆了。是的。就像，哦等等。哦该死。她已经订婚三年了。跟这家伙订婚三年了。天哪。是的。然后吉姆有一段让人心碎的独白。我觉得我会被邀请去参加婚礼吗？噢，吉姆。心碎一地。他让人心碎。一出场就让人心碎。他真的让人心碎。所以吉姆和帕姆之间还有另一个非常可爱、充满调情的时刻。在我们在会议室得知所有人都在传
going to be downsizing. The camera cuts to different groups of people talking about downsizing. But when it cuts to Jim and Pam, we are not talking about downsizing. Who are you guys talking about? We are talking about your cat party. Do you remember this? I do. I do. So this is, I feel like this is really significant and kind of goes on the heels of what we were talking about with Greg wanting to collaborate with actors. So Ken said, listen, I'm just going to roll the camera. You two just talk to each other. Don't push it. Just talk. Make each other laugh. And so here's something you should know is that earlier in the scene, Ken had
要裁员的场景之后。镜头切到了不同的小组，大家都在讨论裁员。但镜头切到吉姆和帕姆时，我们谈论的却不是裁员。你们在聊谁？我们在聊你的猫咪派对。你还记得这个吗？我记得。我记得。所以我觉得这非常重要，有点延续了我们之前讨论的关于格雷格想要与演员合作的话题。所以肯说：“听着，我马上开机拍摄。你们俩就随便聊聊。别太刻意。就聊天。逗对方笑。”所以你们应该知道的是，在这场戏之前，肯曾
asked me if I would pass out papers in the background. Yeah. I only had three lines in the episode. They were, you know, otherwise I was just background, basically, for that, you know, pilot. So he asked me if I would pass out papers. And I had just doodled a little drawing of a cat and I said, you're invited to Sprinkle's birthday party. I just sort of made up that my character had found a cat in the parking lot. I don't know. I was just sort of bored and we all made up backstories. Yeah. I just, I just made up backstory that my character had found this cat in the parking lot. But I think it's really significant because you, in your
问我能不能在背景里发发传真。是的。我在这一集里只有三句台词。除此以外，我基本上就是那个试播集里的背景板。所以他问我能不能发发传真。我刚刚随手涂鸦了一只猫，然后写着：邀请你参加小精灵的生日派对。我只是随口编造说我的角色在停车场捡到了一只猫。我不知道。我当时就是有点无聊，我们大家都编造了背景故事。是的，我只是编造了一个背景故事，说我的角色在停车场捡到了这只猫。但我觉得这非常重要，因为你在自己的
character, actory prep work, decided that your character was a crazy cat lady. I guess I did. Because you kind of decorated your desk with the cat stuff. Now, the prop department that set my desk had a paper clip holder that was a cat laying on its side and it holds paper clips. Okay. I took it from my desk. I still have it. I might have stolen it as a memento. And so I think I was just looking at that and I was doodling and truth be told, there's only about three things I can draw in real life that look like the actual thing. And one of them is a cat. One of them is a cat. That's kind of true for me. I can draw a palm tree. I can
角色的前期准备工作中，决定把你的角色塑造成一个疯狂的爱猫女性。我想我确实是。因为你用猫咪的东西装饰了你的办公桌。话说回来，负责布置我桌子的道具组准备了一个纸镇，是一个侧躺着的猫，用来夹回形针的。好吧。我把它从我桌上拿走了。我到现在还留着。我可能把它当成纪念品顺走了。所以我想我当时只是看着那个东西，然后就在那儿涂鸦。说实话，我现实中能画得像实物的画大概只有三样。其中一样就是猫。其中一样就是猫。这对我来说也差不多。我会画棕榈树。我会
draw a cat. And I can draw a Snoopy. Hey. There you go. And I guess I had just doodled a cat. And so I'd written on, so maybe my poor, like my poor skills at drawing is also what gave birth to this moment. But I drew this cat and I wrote you're invited to Sprinkle's birthday party in the parking lot. And you gave it to me. I handed it to you earlier. And it was weird. I remember getting it in the background of the scene and thinking, I don't know what this is, but I stuck it to my computer monitor. Yeah, it was on a post-it and you stuck it to your computer. So when Ken Kuop has asked me to talk to John about anything to do this
画猫。我还会画史努比。嘿。这就对了。我想我当时就是随手画了一只猫。然后我在上面写着，也许我那糟糕的画画技术也正是这个桥段诞生的原因吧。我画了这只猫，并写道：邀请你参加停车场小精灵的生日派对。然后你把它给了我。我之前把它递给你了。这感觉很奇妙。我记得在场景的背景中收到它时心想，我不知道这是什么，但我把它贴在了我的电脑显示器上。是的，它在一张便利贴上，你把它贴在了你的电脑上。所以当肯·夸帕斯让我跟吉姆聊聊关于这场戏的任何事、
scene, just talk to each other, I noticed that post-it note. And I said, are you going to go something like, I can't remember the cat party on Sunday? And he he's like, oh, no, it's ridiculous. No, definitely not. And then we giggle. And that is the bit that they left in the episode. And that's the birth of Sprinkles. That was the birth of Sprinkles. That turned into this cat birthday party. Greg honed in on that. He was like, what is the cat birthday party? And I said, well, Angela gave me this post-it note about her birthday party for her cat or something. And he loved it. And then for four seasons, we
只要随便聊聊时，我注意到了那张便利贴。我说：“你觉得——”类似于“周日的猫咪派对你会去吗？”然后他回答：“哦，不，太荒谬了。不，绝对不会。”然后我们咯咯笑了。这就是他们剪进正片里的片段。这就是小精灵（Sprinkles）的诞生。这就是小精灵的诞生。它后来演变成了这个猫咪生日派对。格雷格一下子注意到了这一点。他说：“猫咪生日派对是怎么回事？”我说：“哦，安吉拉给了我一张便利贴，是关于她给猫办生日派对的。”他超喜欢这个点子。然后连续四季，我们
discussed Sprinkles until his untimely death. Oh, okay. Yes. That's another episode. I won't make you think about it. Because it's one of my favorite Michael moments too. Yeah. So that was really fun how just these little elements of us in the background sort of being bored and improvising made it into the show. Yeah. It's so special to me. All right. So I have something that I am so curious about. And Jenna, I don't even know if you know this. Fans out there, I don't know if you know it or if we need a text. Dave Rogers, our editor extraordinaire. So my Dwayne Angela fans, did you notice in the pilot episode that Dwight is singing
都在讨论小精灵，直到它不幸离世。噢，好吧。是的。那是另一集了。我不会让你去想它的。因为这也是我最喜欢的迈克尔的桥段之一。是的。所以这真的很有趣，我们这些在背景里无聊并即兴发挥的小细节竟然真的被剪进了正片里。是的。这对我来说太特别了。好的。所以我有个非常好奇的问题。珍娜，我甚至不知道你知道不知道。电视机前的粉丝们，我不知道你们知不知道，或者我们需要联系一下。戴夫·罗杰斯，我们出色的剪辑师。所以我的“德怀特与安吉拉”的粉丝们，你们有没有发现在试播集里，德怀特在收拾桌子时
Little Drummer Boy as he unpacks his desk? Angela. He's singing like, come they told me. And then in season three, I karaoke Little Drummer Boy and Dwight joins in and sings with me. Now, that story is that I was very nervous to sing. I don't like singing in front of people. And and rain as Dwight just jumped in and kind of like supported me. So I wasn't up there alone. And he kneeled down and he held the microphone for me. And I'm just like, Oh my God. I mean, what? That's weird. Crazy. I feel like that has to be a coincidence. I think it's a coincidence. But how and so many fans say to me, like, what amazing synergy it is
在唱《小鼓手男孩》？安吉拉。他唱着，来吧，他们告诉我……然后到了第三季，我唱了《小鼓手男孩》的卡拉OK，德怀特加入进来和我一起合唱。当时的故事是，我当时唱歌非常紧张。我不喜欢在别人面前唱歌。然后雷恩饰演的德怀特就直接加入了进来，可以说是支持了我。所以我不是一个人站在那上面。他还单膝跪地，为我举着麦克风。我当时就想，天哪。我是说，什么？这太奇怪了。太疯狂了。我觉得这一定是个巧合。我认为这是一个巧合。但为什么有那么多粉丝对我说，
that Dwight is singing Little Drummer Boy in the pilot. And then in season three, I sing it to him. Now, did a writer remember that? Was that something that like was or was that just in the subconscious of the show? I don't know. I don't know. You know what I found? I found this article. And I can't remember where I apologize. I found an article that was all about secret messages in the pilot episode. And one of the secret messages that someone points out is that in the scene where Roy comes in the door for the first time, the boom mic dips into frame and someone wondered, was that a nod to the boom operator Brian that
德怀特在试播集里唱《小鼓手男孩》，然后到了第三季我唱给他听，这配合简直绝了。难道是哪个编剧记住了这一点？这究竟是有意的安排，还是这剧本生来就带有某种潜意识？我不知道。我不知道。你知道我发现了什么吗？我找到了这篇文章。我不记得具体在哪了，在此道歉。我找到了一篇文章，全篇都在讲试播集里的隐藏彩蛋。其中一个被指出的隐藏彩蛋是，在罗伊第一次走进门的那个场景中，吊杆麦克风探进了镜头里，有人就在想，这难道是在向我们在第九季才会遇到的
we will meet in season nine? No, that was just an accident. Was it was it foreshadowing to let us know that there are three men in Pam's life, Jim, Roy, and Brian? No, no, that was just a boom operator accident. And they left it in because it's a documentary. Yes, we left that stuff in all the time. That was a thing that we we coveted that. We loved it. If someone, if the camera person fumbled or if the boom accidentally was in shot, we still used it and we could. And that was actually great because sometimes you're on a set and your best take is ruined because of some, you know, technical technical accident on the
收音师布赖恩致敬吗？不，那只是一次意外。这难道是在暗示帕姆生命中有三个男人：吉姆、罗伊和布赖恩吗？不，不，那只是收音师的一次意外失误。他们把它留在正片里是因为这是一部纪录片。是的，我们总是把这种镜头留着。这是我们非常珍视、非常喜欢的一点。如果摄像师失误了，或者吊杆麦克风不小心入镜了，只要能用我们都会留下来。这其实很棒，因为有时你在片场，最好的镜头却因为片场的一些技术
set, but we were able to use all of it. We didn't have to put it on the cutting floor. Okay, so yeah, so no conspiracy. But yeah, I don't know if Dwight singing Little Drummer Boy and the pilot and Angela singing it in Benihana Christmas in season three is just a crazy coincidence, but it's cool, right? It's a pretty cool observation. It's pretty cool. I actually really love these fan theories because I like to think that these accidents or coincidences, if they are accidents, are part of a fun collective unconscious thing that kind of lend itself to the magic of the show. Wow, Jenna, that was really deep. It
事故给毁了，但我们能够把所有的废镜头都利用起来。我们不需要把它们扔进剪辑室的垃圾桶。好吧，所以，没有阴谋论。不过，德怀特在试播集中唱《小鼓手男孩》，而安吉拉在第三季的《班尼哈纳圣诞节》中唱这首歌，究竟是纯属巧合，还是真的很酷，对吧？这是一个相当酷的发现。相当酷。我其实真的很喜欢这些粉丝理论，因为我愿意认为这些失误或巧合——如果它们真的是失误的话——是那种有趣的集体无意识的一部分，为这部剧增添了魔力。哇，珍娜，你这话很有深度。
kind of was. I got real philosophical there. Oh my gosh, I feel like I just had like a vision of what you were like in college or something. Yeah. Like you sat around like maybe like you wore like black turtlenecks and like, I don't know, I was kind of like, I was kind of like Art Show Pam. Art Show Pam. With my turtleneck. Yeah. My jumper. Well, I like it. Spilling philosophy. All right, Angela, what have you got for us? I only had one speaking scene in the pilot and so did Brian. It was back in accounting when Angela and Kevin are trying to figure out who's going to be fired for downsizing. We were really nervous about shooting the
确实挺深奥的。我刚才变得好有哲学意味。天哪，我觉得我仿佛看到了你上大学时的样子。是的。就像你坐在那儿，可能穿着黑色高领毛衣，然后，我不知道，我当时有点像，我有点像是“艺术展帕姆”。艺术展帕姆。穿着我的高领毛衣。是的。穿着我的毛衣。不过我挺喜欢的。满嘴哲学。好了，安吉拉，你给我们带来了什么？我在试播集中只有一场有台词的戏，布赖恩也是。那是回到会计部的时候，安吉拉和凯文在计算谁会被因裁员而开除。我们当时对拍摄这场戏
scene. It's the only time we speak. And it was at the end of the day, Ken Cuapas, who's, you know, we've said the nicest guy was like, go ahead. And I said, um, somebody's going to be fired. It'll probably be me. And Brian, as Kevin says, yeah, it'll probably be you. And Ken came up to me and goes, Hey, um, Angela, can you do it again? And like, just give it like half, give it half. Hmm. So I guess I was like, was I too big? Was I like, somebody's going to be fired. It'll probably be me. Like, and then so I was like, somebody will probably be fired. It'll probably be me. Someone's going to get fired. Is that the exact line?
非常紧张。这是我们唯一有台词的戏。那是在一天快结束的时候，大家都知道肯·夸帕斯是最好的人气导演，他说：“开始吧。”我说：“呃，有人要被开除了。那个人可能是我。”而布赖恩饰演的凯文说：“对，那个人可能就是你。”然后肯走到我面前说：“嘿，安吉拉，你能再来一次吗？只要表现出一半的力道就行。”嗯。所以我想我是不是演得太夸张了？我是不是表现得像：“有人要被开除了。那个人可能是我。”然后我就想：“有人可能会被开除。那个人可能是我。有人要被开除了。”台词到底是怎样的？
Somebody's going to be fired. It'll probably be me. Then he came up and he goes, half of that. I said, Oh, okay. So then I was like, somebody's going to be fired. It'll probably be me. And he goes, half of that. Oh, I said, Oh my god, I'm going to get fired because I'm like an improv sketch comedy actor and clearly I'm too broad. And so ultimately the take they use by the end of it, I literally was like, somebody's going to be fired. It'll probably be me. And then Brian's like, yeah, I'll probably be you. And Ken was like, we got it. I was like, do you want to point out what you noticed about this scene as well? Yes. Kevin, here's
“有人要被开除了。那个人可能是我。”然后他走过来对我说：“收敛一半。”我说：“哦，好吧。”然后我就说：“有人要被开除了。那个人可能是我。”他又说：“再收敛一半。”哦，我当时想：“天哪，我要被开解雇了，因为我是一个即兴小品喜剧演员，显然我演得太浮夸了。”所以最终他们采用的那个镜头，到了最后，我真的就变成了：“有人要被开除了。那个人可能是我。”然后布赖恩说：“对，那可能就是你。”肯就说：“我们过了。”我就想：“你想指出你对这场戏的什么发现吗？”是的。凯文，
my tidbit, guys, is that when I watch this and Brian, I want to call you about it. You just sound like Brian to me. You don't sound like the Kevin voice. Okay, can we play it? I bet it's going to be me. Probably going to be me. Yeah, it'll be you. Oh my gosh. That's Brian. That is Brian's voice. That's not because Kevin would have been like, yeah, it'll probably be me. Yeah, that's a horrible Kevin. We just really did not do that. Oh my gosh, I want to call Brian about it. But when I watched it, I was like, wait a second. Like that's Brian. But I think in the pilot, we are still sort of like figuring out our characters and who they
这是我的小爆料，伙计们，当我看到这一幕时，布赖恩，我想就此给你打电话。你听起来太像布赖恩了。你听起来一点也不像凯文的声音。好吧，我们可以放一下这段吗？我打赌那绝对是：我猜那可能是我。可能是我。对，那肯定是你。噢，天哪。那是布赖恩。那是布赖恩的声音。那根本不是凯文，因为凯文的声音应该是：“对，那可能就是我。”没错，那是个糟糕的凯文模仿。我们当时真的没做到位。天哪，我想为此给布赖恩打电话。但当我看到这一幕时，我想：“等一下，这明明就是布赖恩。”不过我认为在试播集中，我们仍然在摸索我们的角色，以及他们究竟是
were. However, I have to say, Angela. What? I went into the deleted scenes. Oh my God. On the DVD, season one DVD. And there is, this is something we did on the pilot. Some of it was an acting exercise where they called us each into the conference room separately and they just asked us unscripted lines about our characters and about our relationship to other characters. I remember this. It wasn't written. It was not written. We just improvised. So this was sort of, I think, an exercise that Ken wanted to do, that Greg and Ken came up with. In addition to that thing where they filmed us all just working, they also filmed us
什么样的人。不过，我必须说，安吉拉。什么？我跑去看了被删减的片段。天哪。在DVD上，第一季的DVD上。有这样一个片段，这是我们在拍试播集时做的事情。其中一些就像是一场表演练习，他们把我们每个人分别叫进会议室，问了我们一些没有剧本的问题，关于我们的角色以及我们与其他角色的关系。我记得这个。这不是写在剧本里的。这不是剧本里的。我们只是即兴发挥。所以这可以说是肯想要进行的一场练习，是格雷格和肯想出来的。除了让他们拍摄我们所有人工作的画面之外，他们还拍摄了我们
being interviewed in character. And I think Greg thought, this will be great. Maybe I could use some of these little tidbits here and there. Well, there is a series of interviews with each of the members of accounting. Oh my God. Where you guys are all trash talking each other very subtly. And Angela, you have this incredible deleted scene talking head where they ask you about Oscar. Is this where I compare him to a stapler? Yes. Sam, can you pull that up so we can listen to that? Oscar, how do I describe him? He's like a stapler. Do I need a stapler? Yes. But I'm still the one that has to push it down. I did. I improvised that
以角色身份接受采访的画面。我想格雷格当时想，这会很棒。也许我可以在这里和那里用到这些小花絮。好吧，有一系列对会计部门每个成员的采访。天哪。你们所有人都在非常微妙地互相吐槽。安吉拉，你有一段非常精彩的被删减独白，他们问你关于奥斯卡的事。就是我把他比作订书机的那段吗？是的。萨姆，你能把那段调出来让我们听听吗？奥斯卡，我怎么形容他呢？他就像一个订书机。我需要一个订书机吗？是的。但我还是那个必须把它按下去的人。我当时确实这么做了。我即兴想出了这段台词，
because I was trying to think of like what, like, how does Angela see Oscar? And he's just like, he's necessary, but he's a, he ends up being more work for her. Yes. He's annoying. What was so clear to me when I was watching them was this accounting dynamic had already started. Yeah. This little pod that you guys formed, this little trio, it was there from the very beginning. Also, I do have to point fans, all of the deleted scenes are fantastic. Rainn Wilson has some talking heads. There is a long extended deleted scene talking head of him talking to Ken Quapas, who played the documentarian for us. He would ask us the questions,
因为我在试图思考：安吉拉是怎么看奥斯卡的？他就是那种必不可少，但最终却给她带来了更多工作的人。是的。他很烦人。当我看着这些片段时，我最清楚地感受到的是，这种会计部门的化学反应已经开始了。是的。你们这群人形成的小团体，这个小三人组，从一开始就存在了。另外，我必须向粉丝们指出，所有的删减片段都棒极了。雷恩·威尔逊有一些独白。其中有一段很长的加长删减独白，是他和为我们扮演纪录片导演的肯·夸帕斯对话。他会问我们各种问题，
our director, all about where the boom microphone was. Rainn as Dwight was very distracted by the boom. Oh my God. And he was saying, I really need you to move that. Ken says, we can put it in your blind spot. And he says something like, I don't have a blind spot. I've been trained. So it's especially distracting for me. You need to understand that I'm highly trained. And it's just this little like non-presentational conversation between Dwight and the documentarian about how to be mic'd. I just want to say one thing. So many great things that were established in the pilot that you go on to see for years to come. Of course, one
我们的导演，全都是关于吊杆麦克风在哪里的问题。雷恩饰演的德怀特被吊杆麦克风严重分心了。天哪。他说：“我真的需要你把它移开。”肯说：“我们可以把它放在你的盲区。”然后他说了一些类似的话：“我没有盲区。我受过训练。所以这对我来说尤其具有分散注意力。你需要明白我受过高度训练。”这只是一场德怀特和纪录片导演之间关于如何佩戴麦克风的、非常生活化的对话。我只想说一件事。试播集中确立了那么多伟大的元素，这些元素在未来的好几年里一直延续着。当然，其中最重要的一点
of the big ones is the gym versus Dwight, like sort of their battle, right? And the pranks that Jim is going to do on Dwight. And I love that it just started out so simply with Dwight pushing all of Jim's papers back to his desk and then Jim making the pencil wall. That is just ridiculous. Like, well, that was borrowed from the British show. In the British show, they have the same desk war, but instead the gym character piles up a bunch of boxes. He makes a box wall between the desks. And we did that when we filmed the pilot. We had Jim make a box wall. And in fact, you can see it in the background of conference room scenes. You
就是吉姆对阵德怀特，可以说是他们之间的宿敌之战，对吧？以及吉姆将要在德怀特身上搞的恶作剧。我喜欢这一切只是从非常简单的事情开始的：德怀特把吉姆所有的文件都推回他的桌子上，然后吉姆用铅笔砌了一堵墙。这简直太荒谬了。好吧，那是从英国版里借鉴来的。在英国版里，他们也有同样的办公桌大战，不过不同的是，吉姆那个角色堆了一堆箱子。他在两张办公桌之间砌了一堵纸箱墙。我们在拍试播集时也这么做了。我们让吉姆砌了一堵纸箱墙。事实上，你可以在会议室场景的背景中看到它。你
can see a bunch of boxes piled up on Jim's desk. My lady, I'm going to go back and look. Later, when we got picked up, we reshot that scene and turned it into a little pencil thing. And you can also see that rain's hair is a little bit different in the pencil scene compared to the rest of the pilot. It's not as poofy. That's right. Yeah, exactly. Rain as Dwight went through poofy hair phase, which looks like they used a little miniature like rolling brush to blow dry his hair. And then he went through flat parted down the middle phase. Well, rain created the hairstyle for Dwight. And he said before that it is
可以看到吉姆的桌子上堆着一堆箱子。天哪，我要回去找来看看。后来，当我们获得续订后，我们重拍了那场戏，把它变成了一个小铅笔墙。你还可以看到，在铅笔墙的那场戏里，雷恩的头发和试播集的其他部分有点不太一样。没有那么蓬松。没错。是的，确实。雷恩饰演的德怀特经历过蓬松发型阶段，看起来就像是用一个小圆滚刷吹干头发一样。然后他经历了中间分缝的扁平发型阶段。好吧，雷恩为德怀特创造了这个发型。他之前说过，这
based on the hairstyle that he wore when he was a 16-year-old boy. And so he did his own hair for the pilot. That makes me laugh. I've seen those photos of rain. They're crazy. You wore your own clothes in the pilot. I wore my own clothes in the pilot. All right. So the last sort of thing I think we need to talk about is this big prank on Pam, quote-unquote, the scene where Michael fake fires her. Well, he's so excited because Jim has had a very successful prank. And Michael just, he wants to be in the spotlight. He wants to be the funny guy. So he's going to show off for Ryan the Temp and he's going to fake fire Pam.
是基于他16岁时留的发型。所以他在试播集里弄了自己的发型。这让我笑喷了。我见过雷恩那些照片。太疯狂了。你在试播集里穿的是你自己的衣服。我在试播集里穿的是我自己的衣服。好吧。所以我们最后需要讨论的事情，大概就是对帕姆的那个大型恶作剧——也就是迈克尔假装解雇她的那一场戏。好吧，他太兴奋了，因为吉姆的恶作剧非常成功。而迈克尔也想成为众人瞩目的焦点。他想做那个搞笑的人。所以他要在实习生瑞恩面前炫耀一番，打算假装解雇帕姆。
And it of course goes horribly wrong and she ends up in tears. And we shot that scene probably 30 times. Wow. And at the beginning of the scene, you can see everyone in the background kind of getting ready to leave for the day. And all those people had to wait for hours. They would have to start in the background and then we would do this whole scene. Oh, I know, Jenna. I know. I was there. I had to grab my jacket, my coat and my purse, put them down, my coat and my purse. I think of any scene in the entire history of the office, this is the one that I've done the most because we did about 30 takes of it that day. But it was also my audition scene.
结果当然大错特错，最后帕姆泪流满面。我们那场戏大概拍了30遍。哇。在那个场景的开始，你可以看到背景中的每个人都在准备下班离开。所有那些人都不得不等待好几个小时。他们得先在背景里待命，然后我们才能拍完整场戏。我懂的，珍娜。我知道。我当时就在现场。我得抓起我的夹克、外套和钱包，放下它们，我的外套和钱包。我想在《办公室》整部剧的历史中，这是我拍过次数最多的一场戏，因为那天我们大约拍了30个镜头。但这也是我的试镜戏。
This was one of my audition scenes. And so I auditioned for months for this role. I did that scene one time when I auditioned for the role of Pam and I didn't get it. This is such a crazy, crazy bit of trivia. Yes, yes. Your first audition for the office was for the role of Pam. Was for the role of Pam and I wore a pink sweater. What? We both had the same instinct. I wore a pink sweater and my hair down and I was told to look, you know, like not too fancy. So I didn't do too much with my hair and makeup and I went in and I did the scene
这是我的试镜戏之一。所以我为这个角色试镜了好几个月。我当时在为帕姆这个角色试镜时演过一次那场戏，然后我没被选上。这真是一条疯狂的冷知识。是的，是的。你对《办公室》的第一次试镜是为帕姆这个角色。是为帕姆这个角色，我穿了一件粉红色的毛衣。什么？我们俩的直觉一模一样。我穿了一件粉红色的毛衣，散着头发，他们告诉我要看起来，你知道的，不要太刻意打扮。所以我没有在发型和妆容上花太多心思，我走进去演了那场戏，
and it was for a roomful people, the producers. And when we got to the point where Michael fake fires you and you start to cry and you call him a jerk. Yeah. When I called him a jerk, everyone started to laugh. And I thought, I did something wrong. I don't think they're supposed to laugh at this moment. And of course, like, Jenna, you were so brilliant because you brought such a vulnerability to Pam that even though this job sucks and she hates it, she needs it. She needs this crappy job. Yeah. And you really felt her in that moment. You just, my heart broke for her.
面对的是满屋子的制作人。当我们演到迈克尔假装解雇你，你开始哭泣并骂他是混蛋的时候。是的。当我骂他混蛋时，所有人都笑了起来。我当时想，我做错了什么。我觉得他们在这个时候不应该笑。当然，珍娜，你太 brilhante（才华横溢）了，因为你为帕姆赋予了一种脆弱感，尽管这份工作烂透了，她也很讨厌它，但她需要它。她需要这份糟糕的工作。是的。你真的在那一刻感受到了她的情绪。我的心都为她碎了。
And when you call him a jerk, it's just like you're really wounded and it checks Michael in his place of like, that wasn't cool. Well, it's funny because this was a somewhat controversial scene about whether or not it should be included. When Ricky and Steven were counseling Greg, I understand that they told him that he should consider cutting the scene because they said that it's in their pilot and they felt like they always had to fight to come back from it, that it made the boss a little too mean and not, and so later they really leaned into his buffoonery. But Greg fought to keep it in. He thought, no, we're going to, we're going to try it.
当你骂他是混蛋时，就好像你真的受到了深深的伤害，这让迈克尔瞬间清醒过来，意识到：刚才那样做太不厚道了。好吧，有趣的是，关于这场戏是否应该保留，曾引发了一些争议。据我所知，当瑞奇和斯蒂芬给格雷格提建议时，他们告诉他应该考虑删掉这场戏，因为他们说在他们的试播集里，他们觉得每次都要费好大劲才能扭转观众对这种行为的负面印象，这让老板显得太刻薄了，而不是，所以后来他们真正放大了他的滑稽傻气。但格雷格力争保留这场戏。他想，不，我们要试一试。
We're going to let her cry. We're going to let Michael be mean to her. Now, there was an alt line where I think that sometimes instead of saying, you're a jerk, I said, you're a sad little man. And they said, that's too, that's too harsh. You can't come back from that. That is harsh. So here's a little, a little fun tidbit, Jenna. Another tidbit, not a fast fact. A tidbit from Angela Kinsey. When Michael wants to prank Pam in front of Ryan the Temp, Michael as Steve turns to Ryan, BJ, and says, have you ever seen, you know, do you like prank
我们要让她哭。我们要让迈克尔对她刻薄。当时还有一个备选台词，我想有时候我不说“你是个混蛋”，而是说“你是个可悲的小人物”。他们说，这太严厉了。这太严厉了，你没法再扭转局面了。那确实很严厉。所以这里有个有趣的冷知识，珍娜。又是一个冷知识，不是快节奏事实。来自安吉拉·金斯的冷知识。当迈克尔想在实习生瑞恩面前捉弄帕姆时，迈克尔（史蒂夫饰演）转向瑞恩（BJ饰演）说：“你见过吗，你喜欢恶作剧
shows? Have you ever seen punked? BJ was on punk. He was on. He was on season two of punk. So I thought that was a nice little nod that he's looking at someone who was on punked and says, do you like punked? And BJ's like, yeah, like as Ryan. Anyway, that's a Kinsey tidbit for you. So the end of this episode, Pam is been crying and Jim wants to cheer her up. So he puts Michael's world's best boss mug in Jell-O. Now, this was exclusive to our show. So the whole It's not in the BBC version. That's right. The mug itself is set up in an early talking head. And then this convention of ending the episode with Jim doing something sweet for Pam by putting the mug in Jell-O. That was all Greg Daniels idea. And I think it's such a sweet way to end the show.
节目吗？你看过《明星大整蛊》（Punk'd）吗？”BJ曾上过《明星大整蛊》。他上过。他上了《明星大整蛊》第二季。所以我觉得这是一个很好的彩蛋，他看着一个曾经上过《明星大整蛊》的人，问“你喜欢《明星大整蛊》吗？”然后BJ回答说“喜欢”，以瑞恩的口吻。总之，这就是给你们的金斯冷知识。所以这一集的最后，帕姆一直在哭，吉姆想让她振作起来。于是他把迈克尔的“世界最佳老板”马克杯放进了果冻里。这可是我们剧集的独家桥段。BBC版本里可没有。没错。马克杯本身在早期的独白中就铺垫好了。然后以吉姆把马克杯放进果冻里为帕姆做一件暖心的事来结束这一集，
Yeah. And that's the last shot. Oh my God, Jenna. That's it. We just did it. We did it. We did it. We did our first podcast. You guys, we really, we were really nervous. We actually in the middle of doing this, I was getting so nervous that Angela, that Angela made us turn off the microphones and have a dance party to loosen me up. I did. I put on Taylor Swift's paper rings and I made her dance around and get out of her head. I was spiraling. You were. But here's the thing. This is why we're nervous is because the show means so much to us. And we are new, obviously, to the podcast scene and your support has been overwhelming. I literally teared up when we let you guys know we were doing a podcast and just the immediate support from all of you out there. I got a little
这全都是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的创意。我觉得这是给这集画上句号的最温馨的方式。是的。这也是最后一个镜头。天哪，珍娜。这就结束了。我们做到了。我们做到了。我们完成了我们的第一个播客。伙计们，我们真的很紧张。我们在录制过程中甚至紧张到，安吉拉让大家关掉麦克风，跳了一场舞来帮我放松。我确实这么做了。我放了泰勒·斯威夫特的《Paper Rings》，拉着她到处跳舞，让她别胡思乱想。我当时整个人都不好了。你确实是。但关键是，我们之所以紧张，是因为这部剧对我们意义重大。而且我们对播客领域显然还是新人，你们的支持让我们受宠若惊。当我告诉大家我们要开始做播客时，我简直感动得落泪了，大家给出的即时支持让我
emotional. Me too. So I just thank you guys so much and just know how much it means to us that this show that is so special to us keeps finding an audience. It just really means the world to us. It's changed our lives forever. Yeah. Yeah. So thank you. Thank you guys. All right. First one. First one. Send in questions. Yeah. You can send us questions at officeladiesatearwolf.com. If you have any questions about an episode, put that episode title in the subject line and we will, we'll read them all. We'll read them all. And then they also said if you want to leave us a voice memo, we could actually play you asking your question in the podcast, which would be kind of cool. Which would be kind of cool. Yes. All right. You can also find us at officeladiespod
有点情绪失控。我也是。所以我要非常感谢大家，并且希望你们知道，这部对我们如此特别的剧集能够不断找到新的观众，这对我来说意味着整个世界。它彻底改变了我们的生活。是的。是的。所以谢谢你们。谢谢大家。好啦。第一期。第一期。发来你们的问题吧。是的。你们可以发邮件到 officeladiesatearwolf.com 向我们提问。如果你对某集有任何疑问，请把那一集的标题写在主题栏里，我们会全部阅读的。我们会全部阅读。他们还说，如果你想给我们留一条语音留言，我们甚至可以在播客中播放你提问的声音，那不是挺酷的吗？那真的挺酷。是的。好吧。你们也可以在Instagram和Twitter上关注我们，账号是 officeladiespod。
on Instagram and Twitter. Yeah. We're setting those up. And we're going to have a website called officeladies.com and you can find out everything about what we're doing with the podcast. That's a lot of ways to find us. That is. Is it too many? Maybe. I don't know. I'm gonna be like, we get it. We get it. Next week, since we're going in order, we're going to be talking about diversity day. So much fun. So if you want to watch it with us, just watch diversity day by next Wednesday and then we'll talk about it. Yeah. And do you hear that? That's our theme music by my neighbor, Creed Bratton. It's his song, Rubber Tree, with Mr. Ed Helms on Banjo. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is
是的。我们正在搭建这些账号。我们还将拥有一个名为 officeladies.com 的网站，你可以在那里找到我们做播客的所有相关信息。找我们的渠道还真不少。确实。是不是太多了？也许吧。我不知道。我心想，行了，我们知道了。下周，既然我们要按顺序来，我们将讨论“多元化日”。超级有趣。所以如果你想和我们一起看，就在下周三之前看一遍“多元化日”，然后我们一起来聊聊。是的。你听到那个了吗？那是我的邻居克雷格·布拉特森（Creed Bratton）创作的主题音乐。这是他的歌《Rubber Tree》，由埃德·赫姆斯（Ed Helms）先生伴奏班卓琴。感谢收听《Office Ladies》。《Office Ladies》由
produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. Remember, you can listen to ad-free versions of Office Ladies on Stitcher Premium. For a free month of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯联合制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔（Cody Fisher）。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）。请记住，你可以在 Stitcher Premium 上收听无广告版本的《Office Ladies》。若想免费体验一个月的 Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码：Office。本集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。